le 246 l'espagne 56 1188 l'allemagne
41500 et l'iran 29 1406 en termes de
décès le total est de 22 1184 dont 3293
en chine 18 1891 hors de chine et les
pays les plus touchés sont l'italie 7500
3d c'est l'espagne 4145 et l'iran 2234
en france vous le savez nous sommes face
à une épidémie majeure d'extension
nationale et qui continue à s'aggraver
nous avons mobilisé l'ensemble des
ressources de santé mobiliser l'ensemble
des établissements publics et privés
grâce à un blanc blanc avec une
déprogrammation massive sur toute la
france de tous les actes médicaux et
chirurgicaux non urgents et nous
basculons progressivement vers une
surveillance en population une
surveillance dite syndromique qui permet
de repérer les actes médicaux les
consultations mes passages aux urgences
et le recours aux laboratoires de ville
ce soir nous estimons qu'il y à 29 1155
cas confirmés par test pcr mais nous
allons de plus en plus basculé vers une
surveillance adaptée à l'épidémie c'est
à dire à une évaluation réelle du nombre
de cas d'après nos professionnels de
santé cette évaluation est donc faite à
partir d'un échantillon de médecins sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
elle est faite au plus près du terrain
et elle permet ensuite d'adapter nos
chiffres à une extrapolation sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
ce réseau est identique à la
surveillance des grands événements a osé
aux événements notamment climatiques
canicule ou vague de froid et aux
épisodes de grippe saisonnière dans que
tous les hivers cette méthodologie au
plus proche du terrain
remontés par les professionnels de santé
de ville et la méthode considérée comme
de référence en stade épidémique
santé publique france concentre sa
surveillance sur l'activité hospitalière
avec le passage aux urgences les
hospitalisations les hospitalisation en
réanimation et la mortalité hospitalière
elle surveille et elle renforce donc la
surveillance de l'activité de ville etc
en particulier la consultation par sos
médecins ou par des médecins sentinelles
mais aussi l'activité des laboratoires
de ville elle remonte aussi des données
d'état civil transmises par l'insee et
vous savez que nous avons demandé des
remontées de la mortalité dans le
secteur médico social et notamment en
ehpad ces données sont en cours de
consolidation elles seront testés ce
week-end et seront présentées en début
de semaine la mortalité totale je vous
le rappel concerne des personnes qui
sont décédées en milieu hospitalier
décédé en ehpad ou décédée à la maison
et toutes ces données sont évidemment
transmise à l'officier d'état civil en
mairie puis transmises à l'insee et à la
santé publique france en ce qui concerne
les données hospitalières plus de 576
établissements de santé nous ont déclaré
des cas aujourd'hui
treize mille neuf cent quatre personnes
sont hospitalisés pour une infection
qu'ovide de 19
toutes les régions sont concernées dans
les outre-mers réunion martinique
guadeloupe
nous comptabilisons 53 personnes
hospitalisées dont vingt-et-une en
réanimation et nous déplorons deux décès
en martinique et en guadeloupe 3375 cas
graves sont actuellement hospitalisées
en réanimation savez que nous avons des
formes graves chez des adultes jeunes
chez les adultes plus âgés
34 % des patients hospitalisés en
réanimation ont moins de 60 ans et 58 %
ont entre 60 et 80 ans en milieu
hospitalier
nous avons désormais 1696 décès depuis
le début de cette surveillance
hospitalière et nous déplorons
aujourd'hui le décès d'une adolescente
de 16 ans survenue en ile-de-france ce
jour sur l'évolution de la mortalité
toutes causes confondues
nous observons une hausse de la
mortalité par rapport à l'attendu dans
cinq régions grand test qui observe une
hausse de 29 29% sur la dernière semaine
la semaine 12 les hauts de france +12 8%
pour la même semaine bourgogne franche
comté 18 jadue 9% d'augmentation
l'ile-de-france 13,7 pour cent
d'augmentation et la corse 39,2 % il
s'agit essentiellement d'une mortalité
observée chez des personnes de plus de
65 ans je termine par une bonne nouvelle
4948 personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital on voit que ce chiffre
progresse très vite et donc on rappelle
que même s'il ya des formes graves
même s'il ya des décès il ya une immense
majorité de personnes qui guérissent les
qui sortent de l'hôpital ou qui ne vont
même pas à l'hôpital qui restent
confinés à domicile et guérissent de
façon tout à fait naturelle
la surveillance en population maintenant
sur les activités d'hier 3643 passage en
milieu hospitalier soit 18 pourtant 10 %
de l'activité totale des hôpitaux pour
une suspicion de kovy de 19500
intervention de sos médecins
là aussi pour une suspicion de kobe 19
au cours de la seule journée d'hier
en ce qui concerne activités de ville
dans les laboratoires d'analysés
médicales de ville depuis le 9 mars
11500 tests ont été réalisés dont 3491
sont positifs ce qui veut dire que 30%
des tests réalisés sont positifs en
termes de proportion d'hospitalisation
après passage en milieu hospitalier pour
suspicion de co vide on à 37% des
personnes qui restent hospitalisés et la
proportion d'hospitalisation en
réanimation reste stable à 5%
la france fait donc face à une épidémie
de colis 19 inédite sévère rapide
nous devons tous être solidaires les
mesures de confinement sont nécessaires
absolument nécessaire pour freiner au
maximum cette épidémie et éviter la
saturation de nos hôtes
tôt les personnes fragiles ont besoin de
nous pour les protéger nous aînés ont
été et seront gravement touchés pour
sauver des vies restez chez vous nous
avons basculé sur une surveillance en
population une surveillance dite
syndromique cette évaluation comme je
vous l'expliquais est faite grâce à des
médecins volontaires sur l'ensemble du
territoire
ce réseau est identique à la
surveillance des événements de type
canicule ou des événements épidémique de
grippe hivernale
il est connu et reconnu pour la qualité
de ses données et cette méthode au plus
proche du terrain en plus proche de
l'ensemble des territoires et la méthode
de référence en épidémiologie c'est
pourquoi le chiffre de 40 2000 a été
avancé ce matin pour estimer le nombre
de personnes qui ont consulté pour une
probable infections à coronavirus et qui
ont consulté donc leur médecin traitant
la semaine dernière face à l'épidémie et
afin de protéger les citoyens les plus
fragiles le gouvernement a décidé d'un
certain nombre de mesures de protection
concernant les ehpad et établissements
d'accueil des personnes âgées
dépendantes
la suspension intégrale des visites qu
est une mesure douloureuses mais
nécessaires et d'autres mesures
d'organisation interne afin de tout
faire pour ralentir la propagation du
virus
devant l'urgence de la situation des
mesures de limitation drastique des
déplacements ont été évoquées par les
professionnels de ce secteur qui sont
pleinement mobilisés et qui font un
travail admirable quotidien elles ont
évoqué notamment le confinement
préventif en chambre de l'ensemble des
résidents d'un établissement
ces mesures qui sont motivés par
l'urgence sanitaire soulève vous
l'imaginez de nombreux enjeux juridiques
et éthiques
au regard de la préservation des droits
fondamentaux des résidents et notamment
les résidents atteints de troubles
cognitifs et déambulant le gouvernement
souhaite être éclairée en urgence par le
comité consultatif national d'éthique
sur les avantages de telles mesures sur
le plan de la santé publique mais aussi
des conditions à mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir le respect du confinement par
les patients atteints de troubles
cognitifs le gouvernement attendons du
comité consultatif national d'éthique de
savoir si cette
décision paraît justifiée et si oui quel
garde fous devrait être prévu nous
devons faire bouclier de la nation pour
nos personnes âgées et pour les
personnes les plus fragiles autour de
nous nous avons aussi évidemment une
pensée toute particulière pour les
personnes en situation de handicap une
attention quotidienne doit leur être
portée encore plus que d'habitude afin
de leur permettre de pouvoir poursuivre
au mieux leurs activités du quotidien et
surtout conserver une qualité de vie
optimale durant cette période si
difficile du confinement
prenez des nouvelles proposez leur de
l'aide soyons tous solidaires et
particulièrement à l'écouté
enfin vous le savez aujourd'hui un train
médicalisé a traversé la france pour
permettre la prise en charge de patients
graves en situation de réanimation des
zones les plus touchées vers les zones
les moins touchés par cette épidémie
ce tgv sanitaire opération totalement
inédite en france a permis le transfert
dans d'excellentes conditions de vingt
malades du grand test vers les pays de
loire le train est arrivé le déplacement
s'est passé dans d'excellentes
conditions et donc c'est une opération
parfaitement réussie merci à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont permis la
pleine réussite de cette opération
et comme vous le savez ce tgv médicalisé
vient de façon complémentaire à toutes
les opérations qui ont déjà été
effectuées les opérations d'entre elles
internationale et européenne
les opérations de nos forces armées sur
l'ensemble du territoire dans le grand
test en corse et dans nos départements
ultramarins tous les moyens sont donc
mises en oeuvre pour prendre en charge
les patients en france les plus graves
de la façon la plus optimale possible
dans ces conditions tout à fait
particulière concernant la recherche de
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier véran a publié ce jour un décret
qui concerne l'encadrement de la
prescription de la chloroquine cela
permet de garantir une poursuite du
traitement des patients qui sont traités
depuis plusieurs années pour une
pathologie chronique par cette molécule
mais aussi ça permet par un dispositif
d'autorisation temporaire d'utilisation
de faire bénéficier certains patients
atteints du courant d'un virus de cette
piste thérapeutique
notre stratégie et d'adapter rapidement
nos décisions pour toujours mieux
protéger les français nous devrons
respecter l'exigence scientifique pour
toutes les décisions de traitement et
tout faire pour soutenir et développer
vite la recherche au profit des patients
je vous remercie une question de la paix
m
des tests seront disponibles en plus
grand nombre pourra tester les salariés
des ehpad et des services à domicile en
cas de suspicion d'infection afin
d'éviter la propagation du vieux chez
les personnes âgées
oui vous savez que le ministre l'a
annoncé notre objectif est de multiplier
notre capacité de test nous avons acquis
des automates permettant de faire
beaucoup plus de tests dès la fin de
cette semaine
dix mille tests quotidiens
supplémentaires dix mille tests encore
supplémentaires la semaine prochaine
nous serons donc entre 25 et 30 mille
tests quotidiens
il y a aussi des innovations importantes
que nous surveillons de très près en
particulier les autotests tous les tests
rapides comme on l'a dans d'autres
pathologies
et puis il y aura dans probablement peu
de temps dans deux ou trois semaines on
l'espère une autre catégorie de tests
très différentes qui ne recherchera plus
le virus mais bien des anticorps et
c'est un élément encore plus important
puisque si l'on est séropositif pour le
courant navires us avec des anticorps
protecteurs cela veut dire que l'on
n'est immunisé et que l'on nous rompons
qu'on peut être parfaitement mobilisés
sur son lieu de travail sans risque et
d'une part d'attraper la maladie mais
surtout sans risquer de contaminer les
personnes les plus fragiles toujours
pour la paix m
où en est la réflexion du comité
d'experts scientifiques caire sur
l'utilisation des données de
géolocalisation un avis va-t-il est
rendu à ce sujet et si oui quand alors
comme vous le savez il y a deux conseils
auprès du gouvernement le conseil
scientifique qui est saisie notamment de
questions sociétales avec des grandes
questions qui traversent l'ensemble de
la société française
le comité caire est beaucoup plus
opérationnels scientifique technologique
avec une réponse rapide pour le
gouvernement sur des innovations
majeures
donc c'est un filtre d'urgence pour
savoir si telle ou telle innovation doit
être favorisée poussée est mise à
disposition et donc ils ont commencé
leurs travaux ils ont un
un énorme chantier devant eux et qui est
d'analyser les stratégies diagnostiques
et stratégies préventives les stratégies
thérapeutiques
et puis les stratégies de type
intelligence artificielle innovations
numériques et donc ils sont tant ils ont
débuté leurs travaux et nous attendons
d'eux il nous éclaire sur les
perspectives possibles grâce aux
nouvelles technologies qui sont très
nombreuses dans ce champ une question
pour rfi est on certain que la perte
d'odorat et de goûts sont liées aux
covic 19 et at on vu cela en chine et
dans d'autres pays
alors non on n'avait pas vu ça
auparavant et c'est une découverte des
médecins français
effectivement ils ont décrit chez des
sujets jeunes une perte totale de
l'odorat avoir une perte totale du goût
ces personnes sont testées positives
donc il ya bien une relation entre ces
symptômes assez rare finalement et la
présence du virus
ce sont souvent des symptômes bénins
donc les gens ne faisaient pas forcément
attention à ces symptômes ne savais pas
qu'ils étaient contagieux donc c'était
une avancée importante
les nos collègues chinois n'avait pas
noté ces anomalies par contre d'autres
collègues anglo-saxons et canadiens ne
la signale donc les français ont été les
premiers à signaler cette cette
particularité de même que comme vous le
savez nous avons décrit des formes là
aussi atypique chez les sujets très âgés
qui ont moins de symptômes respiratoires
et plus de symptômes digestifs
donc on en apprend chaque jour sur cette
maladie qui est une maladie nouvelle qui
atteint aussi de nouveaux territoires
nous avons probablement des
caractéristiques individuelles
différentes
ce qu'on appelle le génotype nous avons
des des capacités des susceptibilités
génétiques et des réponses une éthique
différentes à différentes infections et
donc le virus progressant de pays en
pays on observe potentiellement cdd des
tableaux cliniques différents
une question pour hospimedia at on des
remontées de la mobilisation du secteur
privé lucas lucratif ou associatif en
termes de lits et de personnel oui il ya
une mobilisation absolument remarquable
et d'ailleurs à chaque fois je parle des
hospitaliers mais il faut inclure
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
du secteur médico-social des
intervenants à domicile du secteur
associatif
c'est une mobilisation
totalement exceptionnel je crois inédite
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
il n'y a plus de différence entre le
public et le privé il n'y a plus de
différence entre la ville et l'hôpital
tous les professionnels qui sont auprès
des personnes âgées tous les
professionnels qui sont auprès des
personnes les plus vulnérables des
personnes vivant en situation de
handicap sont mobilisés et on voit bien
que notamment pour la prise en charge
des cas les plus graves
tous les établissements de santé les
cliniques les hôpitaux les cours aux
hôpitaux les petites structures
tout le monde est mobilisé ce qu'ils
peuvent accepter des malades graves les
prennent part tous et ceux qui ne
peuvent pas aller prendre se propose en
soutien aux établissements de santé donc
c'est vraiment un formidable élan de
solidarité de mobilisation pour aider au
mieux les soignants et pour accompagner
les patients les plus graves une
question de l'opinion concernant le
décret sur l'idh roxy chloroquine il se
bat sur l'avis du haut conseil de santé
publique qui émet des réserves justement
sur son utilisation
pourquoi dans ce cas avoir adopté ce
décret il est totalement cohérent c'est
à dire qu'en pratique il rappelle qu'il
y a les indications et des autorisations
de mise sur le marché pour des maladies
graves et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
rappeler que les patients qui ont des
maladies graves et qui nécessite ce
traitement doivent y avoir accès mais il
encadre aussi l'accès à ces molécules
dans des indications particulières dans
ce qu'on appelle une autorisation
temporaire d'utilisation quand il y a
selon un collège de médecins une
indication à tester cette molécule et je
vous le rappelle plusieurs essais
thérapeutiques sont en cours au niveau
international comme au niveau français
pour produire rapidement des
connaissances sur cette molécule pour
savoir rapidement tout ce qu'on veut
savoir en termes de prévention ou de
traitement sur son efficacité et sur son
absence de dangerosité et évidemment
tous les pays du monde sont attentifs à
ce que nous fassions des essais
cliniques rigoureux pour produire des
connaissances utiles à tout le monde et
surtout utile aux malades une question
de france 2 certains pharmaciens se
demande pourquoi avoir choisi geodis
pour la livraison de masques plutôt que
de passer par les grossistes
répartiteurs
que leur répondez vous alors c'est un
choix qui a été fait pour aller vite sur
les sur la la logistique vous savez que
nous avons eu un une réquisition initial
pour connaître l'ensemble des stocks sur
le territoire national et ensuite il a
fallu rats
pidement faire en sorte que tous les
destinataires et des masques que ce soit
les agences régionales de santé pour le
contact de tracing c'est
l'accompagnement des premiers patients
et de leurs familles les établissements
de santé
et effectivement les officines pour
mettre à disposition les masques des
professionnels de santé de ville et donc
c'est un choix qui a été fait logistique
l'idée étant d'aller vite pour fournir
l'ensemble des officines mais comme vous
le savez il ya aussi des grossistes
répartiteurs et donc les grossistes
répartiteurs vont aussi être utilisé
pour nous aider puisqu'ils connaissent
encore mieux le maillage territorial où
il n'y a pas de choix politiques c'était
un choix pragmatique a été fait par les
experts de la logistique
une question pour libération quand on va
s'effectuer la prochaine livraison de
masques et qui va assurer cette
livraison
alors il ya des livraisons en permanence
puisque nous répondons très vite aux
demandes des établissements de santé aux
demandes notamment des hôpitaux quand il
quand la vague arrive et qu'ils ont des
besoins importants en masques et donc ça
c'est des livraisons qui se font dans la
journée et puis nous sommes attentifs
effectivement à fournir de plus en plus
de masques aux professionnels de santé
de leur fournir en continu et d'adapter
notre offre et c'est ça qui est
peut-être le plus difficile ou à la
présence au nombre de professionnels
qu'il ya autour de l'officine c'est un
travail très important très fin qui
permet d'avoir une réponse la plus
adaptée possible au territoire
donc on est vraiment attentifs aux
derniers kilomètres et à ce que la
distribution soit adaptée aux besoins du
territoire toujours pour libération est
ce que ce est ce que le décret sur la
chloroquine interdit officiellement aux
médecins de ville de prescrire du plaqué
nil aux patients qu'aux vite plus est ce
aussi interdit aux pharmacies de fournir
du plaqué nil aux patients convient de
plus venant avec une ordonnance non il
n'y a pas d'interdît en france les
médecins ont le droit de prescrire
quand la dans le cadre de la mm ou ora
et même sous leur propre responsabilité
il y à ici un cadre d'autorisations
temporaires d'utilisation il ya un
troisième 4 qui sont l'ensemble des
essais thérapeutiques en cours
ces essais thérapeutiques ne sont pas
que pour des patients graves de
réanimation ils sont aussi d'hommes pour
des essais de traitement précoce il de
même y avoir des essais en prophylaxie
en prévention
donc tout ce qui rentre dans le cadre
d'un essai déposé accepté très
rapidement en plus par l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
man et par le comité de protection des
personnes permet de proposer à des
malades de tester l'efficacité de cette
molécule
comme d'autres molécules d'ailleurs
puisque plusieurs pistes sont testés
actuellement pour savoir très rapidement
ce que l'on peut faire ou pas faire avec
l'ensemble de ses pistes thérapeutiques
pour les patients
si on pourra paix quelles sont les
conditions pour avoir accès à un test
dans le cas du dépistage massif où en
sont les autres traitements en cours
compris dans les essais or plaqué ni
alors dépistage massif vous savez que là
encore c'est une réflexion qui est en
cours puisque c'était là notamment la
réflexion de sortie du confinement lac
et un moment où quand on va lever de
confinement il faudra savoir qui est
atteint qui a été atteint et s'il n'y a
pas de risque de contamination de
certains territoires par les simples
flux de population je prends un exemple
si une région à très peu de cas
aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on lève le confinement les
déplacements de personnes qui viennent
de régions où il ya eu beaucoup de cas
pourraient contaminer 7 ce territoire
donc on aura besoin effectivement de ces
tests mais on aura aussi la possibilité
d'avoir les deux types de tests que je
vous ai décrit le test pcr qui permet de
rechercher la présence du virus est ce
qu on a des personnes peu symptomatique
ou asymptomatiques ces derniers
présentant pas de symptômes qui peuvent
être porteuses sans le savoir ou alors
on pourra utiliser en complément la
sérologie qui vous permet de savoir si
oui ou non vous êtes immunisés contre le
virus
donc vous voyez que ça fait partie des
stratégies qui vont d'ailleurs être
analysées et testé par le comité d'
analyse de la recherche le comité qui
est auprès du gouvernement et qui nous
qui nous donne des indications sur la
capacité de ces tests sur leur
sensibilité leur spécificité leur
performance
ça c'est important que les français
sachent que nous disposons de tests
performant et en nombre suffisant
donc c'est un travail qui va avoir lieu
dans les deux ou trois prochaines
semaines pour nous guider sur la sortie
du confinement
quant aux essais thérapeutiques qui sont
très nombreux tous les essais français
sont en ligne ces temps là encore une
innovation
si vous êtes intéressé l'ensemble des
essais en cours peuvent être retrouvés
sur le site du gouvernement sur le site
du ministre de la santé pour savoir
toutes les molécules qui sont en cours
d'exploration
il y a des immunomodulateurs il ya des
corticoïdes en réanimation il y à des
antiviraux il ya des antirétroviraux il
ya des antibiotiques
il y as l'hydroxyde routine en
association pas vous voyez qu'il y a
énormément de molécules qui sont testés
pour produire des connaissances
scientifiques vite et proposer à des
centaines de patients des innovations
thérapeutiques une question pour france
info concernant le décret sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine est ce seulement pour les
cas les plus graves ou pour tous les cas
hospitalisés
tout patient qui rentre dans un
protocole avec l'accord de son de son
médecin responsable peut être un plus
dans un est dans un essai partout le
moment on respecte le cadre de l'essai
comme je voulais dit ça peut concerner
des patients de ville puisque certains
professionnels nous propose des essais
en ville ça peut être des protocoles
concernant des patients en stade précoce
dans un stade tardif en réanimation
donc il ya un panel important de
différence de proposition de traitement
et donc là encore c'est ouvert au public
c'est ouvert au privé
tous les médecins peuvent décider de
participer à un essai thérapeutique et
donc on en où on pousse on encourage on
soutient la recherche tous azimuts sur
les pistes de raquettes une question
pour le généraliste les médecins en
contact permanent avec des patients
qu'ovide 10,9 risque-t-il de contracter
des formes plus grave du fait des
expositions répétées n'y a pas
d'arguments scientifiques particulier on
a des médecins qui maintenant sont des
vrais experts de cette pathologie qui la
détecte très vite qu'ils font beaucoup
de téléconsultation de télémédecine et
c'est là encore une innovation
importante donc il n'ya pas de
connaissances particulières sur une
exposition répétée sinon que comme on le
dit à chaque fois notamment pour la
population générale notre objectif est
en permanence d'appliquer les mesures
barrières d'appliquer la fameuse
distance d'un mètre et d'appliquer la
réduction des contacts et c'est pour ça
et c'est comme ça que nous briserons les
chaînes de transmission et que nous
freinerons cette épidémie et que nous
éviterons au maximum la saturation de
notre service de santé de nous de nos
hôpitaux
une question pour ces news est-ce que la
jeune fille décédée avait des
antécédents si c'est le premier cas à
paris dans quel hôpital signe fort en
saura plus sur le contexte de la magie
dix chez cette personne n'avons pas de
détails aujourd'hui et puis comme vous
l'imaginez nous respectons l'immense
douleur de la famille mais je tenais à
vous à partager avec vous cette
information qui est une information
importante puisque comme vous le savez
les formes sévères chez des sujets
jeunes sont extrêmement rares elles
surviennent de temps en temps pour des
raisons multiples on le voit notamment
dans certaines infections virales
il peut y avoir des formes extrêmement
sévère exceptionnelles et donc nous nous
souhaitons participer à la production de
connaissances d'une part partager avec
vous cette information triste très
triste parce que voilà est vraiment
important que tout soit dit sur ce que
l'on observe en france au jour le jour
nous n'avons pas d'information
individuel n'avons pas d'information
permettant de lever l'anonymat
c'est évident que nous devons respecter
la douleur de la famille donc je ne
donnais ne dirais pas plus sur cette
personne ni sur son histoire ni sur le
lieu du décès et vous comprendrez bien
pourquoi
dernière question pour la paix m quand
sera atteint le pic épidémique en
ile-de-france alors c'est très difficile
d'estimer quand survient le pic puisque
finalement il y a plusieurs aspects qui
interviennent l'aspect de l'impact du
confinement
puisque vous avez compte que nous
entrons désormais dans la deuxième
semaine de confinement a été à peu près
totale à partir de mercredi donc on voit
bien qu'on est désormais un peu plus de
huit jours
je vous ai rappelé que les personnes
malades actuellement ont été contaminées
avant la mise en place du confinement
que partir du moment où on a mis en
place de confinement il ya moins de
contacter les gens sortent moins et donc
qui se contaminent - et donc ils vont
être moins malade nous l'espérons la
semaine prochaine et quand ils seront
moins malades les héros - l'hôpital et -
réanimation donc ça c'est l'objectif de
freiner cette épidémie est de limiter le
pic de limiter la saturation des
hôpitaux
donc nous espérons tous que les
prochains jours seront certes difficile
mais qu'ensuite il y aura une
amélioration qu'il y aura une éclaircie
de toute façon il y aura un jour une fin
à cette épidémie quand nous aurons
réussi à parfaitement appliqué nos
mesures barrières a parfaitement
appliqué les mesures d'une dénonciation
et surtout quand nous aurons des
éléments sur le niveau d'immunité dans
la population